كما ذكرت منك سولوميا وهي سكرتيره لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان الاوكراني
سيده
اوكرانيا تنفي انها هجوم على الكريم ولكن
من له مصلحه في هذا اذا لم يكن الجانب
الاوكراني
اولا
ممكن ان يكون هذا مرتب من قبل الكريممل
وهناك اعلانات من قبل الكرملين
التي تقول انهم سوف
يبحثون عن امكانيه استخدام اسلحه ممكن ان
توقف كي والنظامهم ماذا يعني هذا هذا يعني
انهم لن يستخدموا اسكندر فقط او ما هو
اقوى منه
هناك
مقاطع
فيديو
عن
الهجمات التي تمت على الكرملين راينا ان
حتى العلم لم يتحرك
قد يكون هذا
لتبرير استخدام اسلحه تكتيكيه او نوويه ضد
النظام فيك كيف
ولدينا صفارات الانذار لاكثر من ساعه في
كييفا الان ونعتقد ان
الاوكرانيون يريدون من روسيا ان تتوقف عن
الحرب وعن الهجمات ضد مناطقنا وبالنسبه
لنا هذه العمليات غير نافعه ولا تصب في
مصالحنا لان هذا قد يؤدي لتصعيدات روسيه
خطيره
وما يحدث الان
قد يبرر استخدام اسلحه تكتيكيه نوويه
ولماذا الان في رايك سوف تسعى لروسيا
لتصعيد من هذا النوع استخدام اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه وهو الامر الذي لم تفعله طيله
فتره هذه الحرب
حسب اعتقادي
حتى
الان
القوات الروسيه لا تستطيع ان تسيطر على
ضخموت وعلى مجموعه من المناطق الاوكرانيه
عدا عن ذلك في التاسع من الشهر
لن يكون لديهم ما يعرضوه كمؤشرات لنصر في
المعارك في هذه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه كما يسموها الشيء
الثاني
اوكرانيا تحضر لهجمات عكسيه
واعتقد ان هذا يزيد الضغط والسخونه في
الجبهات على المستوى السياسي الداخلي في
روسيا
ومن الطبيعي ان هذا كله مرتبط مع التاسع
من مايو ومرتبط بتحضيرات الاوكرانيين
للهجمات العسكريه لذلك هم يستخدمون هذه
العمليات الاعلاميه
حيث
سيظهرون انهم كانوا مضطرين للرد
ان
الحرب التي بدات في الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير في العام الماضي
هذه كانت حرب برروها بان اوكرانيا هي من
كانت تحضر لحرب روسيا واعتقد ان
المشاهدين يعلمون جيدا ان روس ان اوكرانيا
لم تكن جاهزه لاي حرب او تصادم مع روسيا
هل تعتقدين اذا انما شهدناه اليوم قد يعني
هجوما مضادا قبل الهجوم المضاد بمعنى ان
الروس قد يبادرون بتنفيذ هجوم
فيه تصعيد كبير قبل ان يبدا الاوكرانيون
هجومهم المضاد الذي يتحدثون عنهم عنهم منذ
فتره
هذا ما تحدثت عنه
ان هذه العمليه هي عمليه تغطيه
لامور قد تتطور
روسيا منذ الحرب التي بدات فيها عام 2014
روسيا تقوم
بتبرير كل ما تقوم به بمثل هذه الظاهرات
تبرير الاسلحه التي يستخدموها وقد يكون
وصلوا لمحاوله تبرير استخدام اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه ولهذا نحن
ننكر اي صله لنا بهذه الهجمات قد تكون هذه
هجمات استفعلها افتعلها الروسيين لتبرير
الهجمات التصاعديه على اوكرانيا التصعيديه
على اوكرانيا
لتبرير الاعمال من قبل النظام الروسي في
اوكرانيا هل الاوكرانيون مستعدون لتطور من
هذا النوع وهم منذ زمن طويل وهم يحذرون من
امكانيه ان يستخدم الروس اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه
الشعب الاوكراني متحضر
لن اقول
ان هناك اي طريقه للتجهيد لهجمات من هذا
النوع ولكن هذا هو الواقع وكوننا نقوم
بالتحضير هذا ايضا شيء حقيقي وجنودنا ايضا
مستعدين ويستعدوا للهجمات العكسيه وهذا
واقعي واذا ما حصلت اي هجمات صاروخيه على
المناطق السكانيه وعلى مراكز المدن
الاوكرانيه
هذا يعني ان لاوكرانيا سيكون رد قوي جدا
ضد روسيا
وهذا يعني انه سيكون هناك نهايه لهذا
النظام وتفكه النهايه ما بقي بعد الاتحاد
السوفياتي وسوف تكون روسيا منعزله تماما
عن العالم المتحضر منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
كان رئيس زلينسكي يعبر عن خيبه امله في ان
حلفائه لا يقومون بما يكفي كان الوضع
مختلفا تمكن هو بعد ذلك من
يعني من استقبال عدد من زعماء العالم هو
الان ليس موجودا في كييف موجود في فنلندا
يستطيع ايضا ان يقوم بزيارات
للخارج زار حتى الولايات المتحده هل يعتقد
وما زال الاوكرانيون يعتقدون ان حلفائهم
لا يقومون بما يكفي لدعمهم
ان في اي حرب هناك رياضيات بسيطه حيث تحسب
المدفعيه والالاف منها والذخيره والمعدات
كل هذا يحسب بالرياضيات بسيطه بالطبع من
الصعب ان نقف ضد اليه عسكريه
خطره
مثل روسيا الفيدراليه ومن الواضح اننا
نحتاج للكثير
همم هذه
الحرب بهذه المساحه
هي حرب ليس لها سابق منذ فتره طويله في
اوروبا ولكن
لدينا ما لدينا الان وعلينا ان نحارب
بالوسائل المتاحه
وفي
النهايه العالم المتحضر يجب ان يقف بجانب
اوكرانيا
شكرا
جزيلا من كييف سولوميا
سكرتيره لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان
الاوكراني